[Music]
in today's eye on money we are looking
at a few easy ways to build up your
retirement savings research shows that
before the pandemic
about 85 percent of americans had at
least some form of savings for
retirement but due to financial strains
this past year
one survey found 27 percent of people
stopped saving
or reduced their savings with more
companies now hiring and more people
finding jobs many americans are able to
start thinking about
saving for retirement once again and so
we go now to cbs news business analyst
jill schlesinger
who joins us for more on all this jill i
love this segment because we're doing it
very simple step by step and step one is
how do you begin to start saving for
retirement
you start small and you increase
incrementally
and when i mean start small if you work
for a company
you can put just one percent of your pay
into the retirement plan this may
actually work out to maybe
20 or 25 bucks per pay period but you
start there
and what's really great is that some
plans allow you to automatically
increase that but maybe you could
automatically increase it
see how it goes look the limit for a 401
k or a 403 b this year it's
hundred dollars many people are not
going to get to that maximum level
if you're over the age of 50 you can put
up to 26 000
so you can do one of those types of
plans and get
really far alternatively you could maybe
if you don't work for a big company and
doesn't have a retirement plan you can
start an ira
you can go up to 6 000 in an ira 7 000
if you're over 50 and again you could
start really small
most of the investment companies out
there allow you to use
small dollars to fund these plans do
something
start small go slowly so people hearing
these different acronyms how can they
decide which
plan is the right plan for them and
their lives
i think that normally what is really the
path of least resistance is if your
company or your organization
offers some sort of retirement where
they can pull money directly from your
paycheck
that's the easiest way to go we know
that people
save more for retirement when they work
for those organizations
that allow you to do so now for others
again a lot of companies don't actually
offer these plans
you could use an ira or a roth ira
big difference between these two plans
is just when you get a tax benefit
if you use a regular traditional ira
that gives you a tax benefit today
you save your whole career when you're
age 59 and a half you can
access that money when you take it out
later it gets taxed
with the roth version you don't get any
tax benefit today but
later when you take the money out no
taxes do
so these are all great options use what
again
is the easiest for you many of the big
houses out there they do make it a lot
easier today than they did in the past
i've always heard you say jill that
everybody should have an emergency fund
easier said than done these days
two questions about that how much should
be in your emergency fund
number one and number two should it be
separate from your retirement fund
i'm going to start with the second part
absolutely separate from your retirement
account and here's why
what we know is that when people put
money into their retirement
we want that tax benefit to accrue to
them if you have to go
into that account because there's an
emergency and pull the money out before
you're age 59 and a half
you could be subject to a penalty and
you have to pay taxes
now as terms of how much here's the
really good
news of the pandemic the savings rate
has gone
sky high it's amazing to see and what
we're hoping for is people use the
experience of having a little bit of
extra money
maybe it's a tax refund maybe it's a
stimulus check
you're trying to get six to 12
months of your living expenses in an
account that's accessible to you i know
that's hard to do
but i really think it's simple we
learned that lesson last year we really
did
jill that is hard we've got about 30
seconds left i am curious if you do have
to pull money from retirement because a
lot of people do
what's the smart way to do it well if
you did it last year the cares act gives
you a lot of benefits so first of all if
you withdrew money last year from a
retirement account you've got
three years three tax years to pay that
tax bill so that's huge news
if you borrowed from your account there
were much more generous rules applied
through the cares act
talk to your employer get that repayment
started
and do the best you can again little bit
at a time
habits are hard to form easy to break do
the best you can that's good advice
for all things including retirement jill
schlesinger thank you very much